Olá você saber que 25% da população tem
gordura no fígado que também é conhecido
como doença hepática gordurosa não
alcoólica você pode estar entre esses
números sem nem saber muitas vezes
acreditamos que problemas no fígado só
afetam quem consome álcool em excesso
mas a verdade é bem diferente E
sinceramente é bem alarmante o que é
ainda mais preocupante é que essa
condição está se tornando cada vez mais
comum não apenas entre adultos mas
também entre crianças que em idade
precoce já estão sendo diagnosticadas
com gordura no fígado isso é um sinal
Claro de que precisamos prestar mais
atenção à nossa saúde e também mais
atenção à nossas crianças quando
pensamos em manter o nosso fígado
saudável suplementos podem ser grandes
Aliados existe uma dupla poderosa que
pode ser fundamental na redução da
gordura do fígado a redução da gordura
do fígado não AL
aquela que não tem ligação direta com
consumo de álcool bem pessoal o fígado é
um dos órgãos mais incríveis e
dispensáveis do nosso corpo responsável
por mais de 500 funções vitais que
mantém a nossa saúde em equilíbrio eu
não vou detalhar aqui todas as funções
nesse vídeo mas eu deixo o link na
descrição para quem quiser saber mais
sobre a importância desse órgão pense no
fígado como centro de processamento de
purificação do nosso corpo ele divide
essa função com os nossos rins então o
fígado faz de tudo um pouco ele armazena
vitaminas libera glicose produz
colesterol e Secret bile que é essencial
para digerir gorduras isso não é tudo
ele também metaboliza substâncias
químicas e desintoxica compostos nocivos
em outras palavras o fígado é um
verdadeiro herói silencioso cuidando da
nossa saúde a cada segundo e tem um
detalhe que torna o fígado ainda mais
fascinante Ele é o único órgão do corpo
que pode se regenerar Isso significa que
mesmo se ele sofrer danos ainda tem a
capacidade de se reconstruir e continuar
desempenhando suas funções vitais desde
que receba o cuidado necessário a tempo
desde que ele tem o suporte necessário
Então vamos falar sobre suplementos que
podem fazer uma grande diferença na sua
saúde e na saúde do seu fígado eu quero
começar destacando uma dupla genial de
suplementos que quando combinados tem
demonstrado em vários estudos resultados
realmente promissores no combate a
gordura do fígado a gordura hepática não
alcoólica e você com certeza quer saber
quais são vamos lá resposta é a
Bergamota e Alcachofra então esses dois
compostos naturais são ricos em
substâncias bioativas que não só ajudam
a Reduzir a gordura acumulada no fígado
mas também promovem a saúde geral e
combate a inflamação então em estudo
realizado em 2020 com 102 participantes
esses suplementos combinados mostraram
resultados interessantes Então nesse
estudo após 12 semanas de uso houve uma
redução significativa na gordura
hepática especialmente entre os
participantes com mais de 50 anos onde a
redução chegou a 15% isto é uma melhora
expressiva e é um ótimo indicativo de
que essa combinação pode ser muito útil
pode ser um grande aliado paraa saúde do
fígado a saúde hepática
mas antes de você sair correndo atrás de
comprar esses suplementos é importante
destacar que os participantes desse
estudo também fizeram mudanças na sua
alimentação seus hábitos de vida então
eles adotaram a famosa dieta
mediterrânea se você ainda não conhece
eu tenho um vídeo explicando tudo sobre
essa dieta eu vou deixar aqui o link na
descrição para você conferir depois bem
agora vamos entender um pouco mais sobre
esses dois super ingredientes o primeiro
deles é a Bergamota é uma fruta cítrica
uma fruta amarga conhecida como Citrus
bergamia Risso ela é especialmente
valorizada pela alta concentração de
polifenois como os flavonoides que tem
uma ação um protetor incrível contra o
estresse oxidativo no fígado Além disso
esses compostos ajudam a quebrar as
gotículas de gordura no fígado em um
processo chamado lipofat Ou seja a
Bergamota não só impede o CBO de gordura
no fígado como também facilita a sua
eliminação e assim melhorando a função
hepática como um todo já o cachofra
conhecida cientificamente como Sinara
cardunculus é um verdadeiro tesouro pra
saúde do fígado ela contém uma
substância chamada sinar picrin um
terpeno com propriedades
antiinflamatórias e antioxidantes
potentes e além disso a cachofra é rica
em outros compostos que reduzem o stress
oxidativo e combatem a inflamação
ajudando a diminuir tanto a inflamação
quanto o acúmulo de gordura no fígado
então se você foi diagnosticado ou
diagnosticada com doença hepática
gordurosa não alcólica Essa dupla pode
ser uma excelente adição ao seu cuidado
agora sobre eficácia desses suplementos
em caso de doença hepática causada pelo
excesso de álcool Ainda não temos
estudos não temos dados específicos Mas
eu acredito que possam ajudar talvez não
de maneira tão significativa Quanto é o
caso da gordura hepática de origem não
alcoólica bom já falamos sobre uma dupla
poderosa mas agora eu quero destacar
rapidamente mais dois suplementos que
provavelmente você conhece já ouviu
falar e que podem fazer uma grande
diferença não só na gordura do fígado
mas em qualquer condição que deixa o
fígado sobrecarregado seja por doença
alcoólica ou não a famosa silimarina
derivada do Cardo Mariano e a raiz de
dente de leão Então vamos começar pelo
dente de leão que é uma planta que tem
um efeito diurético natural o que ajuda
o corpo a eliminar toxinas de maneira
mais rápida e eficiente e Isso é ótimo
pro fígado porque facilita o processo de
se livrar de substâncias nocivas Além
disso essa raiz também auxilia no
equilíbrio dos níveis de Açúcar do
sangue que é um ponto muito importante
para manter o fígado saudável e também
ele em pleno funcionamento bem agora
falando do Carlo Mariano a fonte da
silimarina temos aqui um suplemento que
já é utilizado há milhares de anos para
dar suporte para apoiar a saúde do
fígado mas não só do fígado mas também
dos in e da vesícula biliar A semim
Marina é um flavonoide com uma longa
lista de benefícios pro fígado sendo
muito bem documentada na literatura
científica por quê Porque ela atua como
poderoso antioxidante combatendo os
radicais livres que podem causar muitos
problemas entre eles inflamações e
lesões hepáticas Além disso A serim
Marina tem a capacidade de bloquear
entrada de toxinas nas células do fígado
e a assim vai promover a Regeneração
celular nesse Nobre órgão em outras
palavras ela ajuda a manter o fígado
mais forte e saudável e tem mais a
silimarina é especialmente útil para
reduzir os efeitos negativos das toxinas
medicamentos e até do álcool no fígado
por isso ela é amplamente reconhecida
como dos melhores Aliados quando o
assunto é proteção do fígado proteção
hepática já que estou falando de
suplementos que fazem diferença na saúde
do fígado eu não posso deixar de falar
lá deixar de mencionar um verdadeiro
Coringa que traz grandes benefícios para
várias condições de saúde e tem um papel
especial quando o assunto é fígado nós
estamos falando do nac a n
acetilcisteína esse suplemento é um
precursor na produção o famosíssimo
importantíssimo glutationa que é um dos
antioxidantes mais poderosos que o nosso
corpo Fabrica e que é fundamental para
desintoxicação e proteção do fígado por
isso nac é um suplemento de suporte
extremamente interessante importante se
você está falando se você está lidando
com uma doença hepática e mesmo se você
não tem uma condição específica o nac
vai ser um grande aliado ele pode ser um
grande aliado para melhorar a função
desse órgão desintoxicar E protegê-lo
então se você tem uma doença crônica no
fígado nac pode ser muito benéfico e se
você já passou por uma intoxicação com
medicamentos por exemplo como tomar
muito
paracetamol isso vai sobrecarregar o seu
fígado na hora que ele for metabolizado
esse medicamento o nac vai ajudar a
minimizar esses danos inclusive o nac é
usado como antídoto para toxicidade do
paracetamol do tilenol que pode esgotar
os níveis de glutationa e causar sérios
danos hepáticos então pesquisas
publicadas em revistas científicas
mostram que a suplementação com nac pode
melhorar a função hepática até em
pacientes com esteatose hepática
avançada que é uma forma mais grave da
doença hepática gordurosa pessoal usar
suplemento é algo que eu sempre falo
aqui no canal como uma estratégia
inteligente Especialmente quando estamos
falando de suporte ao fígado eu trago
aqui constantemente informações sobre os
benefícios do suplementos mas é
importante nunca se esqueça é
fundamental prestar atenção em um ponto
a suplementação é uma ótima estratégia
mas ela não vai ser eficaz ela não vai
fazer milagre sozinha se você não fizer
o básico se você não cuidar do seus
hábitos de vida de forma geral o
suplemento por si só não vai corrigir ou
com ter um problema mais sério como uma
esteatose hepática pense assim você pode
estar tomando suplemento para ajudar na
desintoxicação do fígado mas se ao mesmo
tempo continuar consumindo coisas que
vão atrapalhar vão prejudicar o seu
fígado como é o caso da bbid alcólica
como é o caso do açúcar do doce da
frutose em excesso dos refrigerantes dos
produtos Ultra processados em geral
excesso carboidratos refinados como é o
caso do Fast Food você estará
sobrecarregando esse órgão e impedindo
que ele se recupere se regenere de forma
adequada mesmo usando suplemento é como
tentar limpar uma sala enquanto alguém
continua jogando sujeira no chão Ok
então para que o suplemento possa fazer
realmente diferença é fundamental adotar
uma alimentação correta equilibrada
também praticar atividade física regular
e manter os hábitos de vida saudáveis no
geral assim você cria um ambiente
favorável para que o fígado se recupere
e também para que o suplemento possa
agir de uma maneira mais eficaz e
realmente cumprir o seu papel entendido
Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no se coração
você é feira